[Music]
father
to actually take us through the health
and safety issues of the day
thank you thank you who's present
when you're walking around here there is
a policy for masks to be worn
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
of us is going to be treating it as a
mature alert
and if you could head out of these two
[Music]
doors
[Music]
use the before we start
thank you ladies and gentlemen
as you are all aware this is the first
time when we have been able to meet in
person since march 2020.
during the past months when we have had
to work virtually many things had to
change
with adopting a more structured approach
which worked well
i would like to continue these practices
now that we are meeting
before i hand over to alumnaker our
senior government officer
who will take us through today's
proceedings i would like to express my
thanks to councillor jane barry for her
support as my vice chair
during the past term and to welcome alan
powell
to his new role as vast chair for the
current year
and then take us through the procedure
for the day
after which i've asked principal clark
to confirm
[Music]
is not mean by the street it is the
audio record
and this audio recording will be placed
on the council's website
as soon as possible the meeting itself
[Music]
based on all the evidence
[Music]
however
[Music]
we've got members of the committee and
we've got political groups
this planning committee is a political
group and i think
we agreed that we would not be having
any political groups written on it so
can i ask why it was done
and if it
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
um
who won't be joining us
[Music]
[Music]
members are requested to declare the
existence and nature of any disposable
human interest and reward other
interests not already on their register
of interests if
have we received any declarations in
[Music]
advance
[Music]
[Music]
and this will be amended
is
[Music]
thank you all those things
[Music]
on the fifth application has been
withdrawn so that the applicant can
resubmit authentic plans
this application will now be heard at
the gi meeting
as you can see each application has its
own report marked as agendas
[Music]
however this morning we will only be
dealing with the first application
ned 20
[Music]
the other applications will be taken
this afternoon
before we do this i would like to
explain
benefit to
[Music]
[Music]
thank you this is
[Music]
[Music]
the planning officers to refer members
to make comments
updates received since the agenda of
issue
the late access to gender supplements
have been published on the council's
website
and hard copies will be circulated to
you
the planning officers will then give a
brief presentation setting out the
application plans
and photographs on the site members of
the seat
are copies of this which they are asked
to follow
[Music]
each seeker
[Music]
members of the committee will have an
opportunity to ask speeded questions
if necessary to clarify anything they
have made
when we are headed for all speakers on
an application
the chair will then open the meeting of
the debate um
and please be aware then you will not be
allowed to participate
further from that vote
as you are aware this meeting is being
recorded
and this recording will be placed on the
council's website
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
zero one zero five is incorrect and the
proper title is asked for the officer
report
so i apologize for that
alteration at this stage at the time
that the application is now
asked for that on page 11.
thank you in line with our normal
practice i'm going to ask the planning
officers to tell us
reports that have been produced by the
planning manager to give a brief
presentation
[Music]
i ask members to
until the end
[Music]
cycle is outlined on an application for
the construction
of up to 80 wellings and associated
works
all month is reserved accepted access is
a major government affecting the public
rights
[Music]
so page two presentation shows the
site shaded in orange you'll see the
access from the top road comes down oaks
farm lane
into the site footpath crosses the side
from the
from the east and goes to the south side
and
over to the west is dark
the next couple of slides are the
illustrative master plan
layout of the site which shows the
access
mode online
[Music]
example
[Music]
so slide six this is the access
improvement details for oaks farm lane
as you can see there's going to be 5.5
meters of width
and then two meters provided and winding
into the site
[Music]
the next slide is the view west along
top right
top row is the tomorrow limit the speed
camera
[Music]
the next slide page nine is the view
down in oaks farm lane
and you can see there's quite a mix of
mix of users down there
residential on the left-hand side of the
bottom there there's
some commercial premises and the care
[Music]
[Applause]
and the access will be just behind the
lorry
that you can see in the background
the next slide let's just view back up
hopes frontline
see the business uses on the right
[Music]
and some residential
now the next slide is a bit further down
post only looking back
towards where the access into the side
will be
and to the right hand side you see the
rails
[Music]
[Music]
and the next slide is a new sound away
from the side since the old timeline
continues
to the left of that slide and you can
see the piles which brought
to the south of the application site
and the next stage
[Music]
is
so the next slide is from the footpath
where the
front lane goes into the application
site and this is the approximate
location of the entrance
of the united application
[Music]
[Music]
so you probably make out some of the
properties that are on top
road on the left side and the pylons
which cross to the south of the
application
and our moves down the dark lanes
so this next slide is taken from a bit
further down dark plane
and it's viewed east across application
sites
and the next slide is right in the
southwest corner
of where the original site used to link
to the dark lane so
you see the pipeline
horses there but these application sites
behind the trees
you can just make out the properties on
the
[Music]
this
just a little bit further on and so you
can see
into the application side there you can
see the cabinet on the right hand side
on the top rope
the trees and the hedgerow you can see i
believe the
good specimens will be retained
and this immediate kind of area will be
it's illustrated where the open space
and the attenuation base will be
moving on this is a view north from the
footpath this is
close to the western edge of the
application site so you can see the
hedge has been put
[Music]
all the applications
this is looking north towards the spine
top row
and this is right
[Music]
you know this is right in the middle of
the application
[Music]
[Music]
a smaller
[Music]
slide 27 just shows properties
on top road and there's a mix of ground
streams you can see there
next slide is from a very
[Music]
across the applications
they're just from close to the access
point
you can see the careful properties
and slide 32 is the last photo taken
from within the application sites
and this is from backward results where
the footprint means oaks farm lane
so the full path is on the left
[Music]
[Music]
the application site
each concludes the presentation thank
you
i'm now going to write
[Music]
as members you can ask them to clarify
any much
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
you can use
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
from the slides that were presented to
us there
are a number of houses which have
on-road parking as well
and the road is as you will as many
people will know
a main road through to between malta and
chesapeake
um it's incredibly busy at rush hour
throughout the day and the parked cars
on the road
only more challenging
now i am concerned with uh
i speak for residents as well with the
amount of traffic that this new
development
may add to the road fast
i think it poses a danger for
pedestrians
and for most like as well as an
increased
pollution risk to residents in the
immediate area
the second point relates to earth and
it's
about a potential access room to the
rear of the
terrace houses that you see on the sides
um as i mentioned they
have on-road parking which is
problematic for numerous reasons
living very busy roads and when
the when this application was first
many of you will know that there was a
proposed access route
down access road on dark lane which is
now not the case
now when asked about the risk of cars
coming
out of oaks on lanes and left towards
chesterfield
so going west he i think he was
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
impact of building
[Music]
impact on our gp service which we share
with brilliantly our
primary school um
no thank you very much
but we need to balance disney with our
duty to protect nature
and the character of the village and
surrounding countryside
kayla is still a village and should
remain in its current boundaries
and not being allowed to spread into
open countryside
the proposal to build on green fields is
not an
acceptable proposition and whilst we
cannot balance the endangered speeches
it is it is an infant system enhanced
trees plants animals and insects
all of which need our collective efforts
to preserve them
climate change again is a real threat
and again
if we allow trees hedges and plants to
be destroyed
this contributes to this no match
remedial planting of guns and trees can
possibly replace
existing habitats the government
once having a housing agenda also has a
green countryside agenda
and this cannot just relate to
protecting national parks
but it relates to all countries this
mean
to preserve has particularly come to the
forefront
as open seemed critical to people with
well-being
if we allow green things to continue to
be built on
then in years to come it will mean that
people will actually have to travel
to find such spaces green beltline
should remain
[Music]
applications later is so
clever attempted
is the repurposing of abandoned pubs
issued retail and business sites in the
area
if we utilise them it means that there
are no big developments between
fairies
[Music]
[Music]
but this does not mean it has to be
approved if houses are to be built
then they need to be very much limited
to 10 or 20
as any additional traffic could prevent
ambulances or violent staff get
into the hospital
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
and nationally this has been in place
for
a number of years and through absolutely
no matters i think it's just a complex
deal health
care um engaged with um development
plans
hospitals practices
[Music]
um
which means directly between household
population growth
and the increasing housing and the
impact
of the hospital because you imagine from
millions of data sets naturally
it's very easy to make that correlation
making requests where the postcodes are
directly with the
hospital and what we're doing is sent
out
the way you did the financial for it you
can quite easily demonstrate
and the population increases quite quite
two to three year lag between that
funding coming back into the hospital
so what that does is
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
thank you follow any questions
no thank you i've got one
more speaker that's the agent dan abbott
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
in this regard the proposals will form a
logical sustainable extension
that's australian available services
facilities
receive our planning
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this will include bungalows
[Music]
is
infrastructure and landscape corridors
provide accessible green space
and new recreational groups connecting
with local footpaths used by new
assistant residents the application is
supported by
robust assessments concerning various
matters
in particular this includes a thorough
transport assessment which consists of
[Music]
demonstrations
[Music]
[Music]
city this includes county highways
locally for authority
environments agency coal authorities
deliveries
the council's environmentality new york
shores
in conclusion being minded with payload
shots credentials
and no objections from statutory
consultancies to being raised
in the commission's very possessiveness
clearly supposed to propose
an approach we welcome your support from
your honest recommendations
thank you are there any questions
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
and it's all about uh
[Music]
the parish council response response
but just as this
is a transport assessment will be
considered
using both uh
[Music]
[Music]
thank you um yes essentially um
[Music]
responses
[Music]
[Music]
an updated transport assessment was
submitted with the revised scheme
just to speak the discussions with
county highways
authorities
[Music]
is
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
the application is designed
so the detail of the specific um
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
um relevant calculations
within the flow risk assessment would be
such that
any output would be a better greenfield
runoff rates because the drainage
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
um
[Music]
there's a number of houses on the
opposite side of the road
with no footpath no potential division
yet they're going to have a huge volume
of traffic you're actually creating one
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
if
[Music]
is a statutory council which is the
highway of authority
having requested additional works beyond
the site boundary they've obviously
considered
the trust
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
last year and i think we're all aware
the
traffic on eighth second last year
there's no resemblance to
traffic in normal in those commerce
times
uh i'm very concerned about
[Music]
the county
[Music]
the trade
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
and that was compared with the data that
was observed
in terms of the trip rates in september
last year now where
the observed from the transport
consultants
that remained as such where the
data in cash for this application was
lower
than tft resources
methodology now in terms of the uh
[Music]
there is any condition
geophysical surveys and also if required
[Music]
[Music]
manager and other officers
[Music]
application
[Music]
and be
[Music]
if anyone indicates that they wish to
move the motion before i
said that would be possible i will be
prepared to take them
the same things apply
[Music]
thank you are there any questions for
our answers
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
21 below
[Music]
an open space
[Music]
is
[Music]
they have no objections
[Music]
thank you any other questions
[Music]
[Music]
because basically if somebody moves in
and they're there for
20 30 years and their health condition
deteriorates and then have to move
so all i think is that there's a council
i'll be asking that some of these houses
are done
so that people can stay there
indefinitely the process are done so
that people in wheelchairs can reach
them
you know things like that which is
really important for people's
lifestyle basically
if i may issue a school in canada
[Music]
[Music]
thank you any further questions
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
search body saw any 106 contributions
in this case initially um i believe it
was a
request for secondary
education provision but defending plans
[Music]
any other
[Music]
the side is outside
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
any other questions
no thank you okay thank you
and that leads us to the final part of
the process our discussion about what
we've heard
what we think and what we want to decide
but before we're going
further reminds us about emotions
right thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
the reasons for moving the motion
insults recommendations
should surprise
[Music]
that doesn't mean that the
recommendations are automatically
approved
rather we need to take a possible
decision through a further motion
payment recommendations action
this will need to be approved by the
committee
thank you chad thank you
yes i'm not sure
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
and i've also got considerable concerns
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
we've got to be very very careful that
there are
you know true grounds a lot of these
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
objections to them and therefore has
been
activated on a number of occasions of
them
unless there's evidence before you will
go against the counterparts coming from
the
statutory quantities and your answers
[Music]
[Music]
you'll learn from the pack both in
respect of the
clinical christian group and also the
nhs from zelda in the hospital
whilst there was a brief conversation
with
officers in terms of the hospital itself
we haven't received any formal
comments or requests or section 106
contributions to respect of that matter
so it's nothing
before us unless grain and contradictory
there's nothing before accounts
[Music]
[Music]
and it's
[Music]
how does an application
[Music]
which you must if you're concerned about
the scheme
have some concern about the harm that
will take place
to help land that lies outside the
second communists and as we've shared
the
advice we have from our landscape
consultant is that there is no
particular
special harm to the area now included in
the application site although that's not
the case
and the application was originally
submitted so from our office point of
view whilst we acknowledge knowledge
sidewise outside the segment it's
harm outside that it's not considered by
officers
in balancing sustainable development the
overriding and that's our recommendation
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and this is we need
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i would like to recommendedly accept the
author's recommendation
ascendant thank you council cooper
and before any works made guided
[Music]
yes
[Music]
um
on the grounds that it has not been
identified
as a residential development in either
the existing or imaginable plan
that it is
[Music]
um
[Music]
i've asked him just to agency
[Music]
in respect of particularly access
and reverse doing that and other than
that
you'll be the first to design massive
detailed matters
and second point just for the council
or any policies on the publication draft
vocal plan to be
added also review this reference to that
and
policies ss1 ss9
um
[Music]
is
[Music]
um
i'm
[Music]
oh
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
against
[Music]
[Music]
against
[Music]
thank
[Music]
thank
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
has
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
masks
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
and these are all
[Music]
for the same um as the previous
applications before by
two red clients who will strongly
encourage the committee
consider carefully the representation
from many investors
who are very apprehensive and their
justification for
future protection mainly green belts
and progress the key issues are
the green belt determining
the similar application constitutes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i
[Music]
[Music]
issues on progress the southern side has
been prone to stimulating bullying
issues
development has shared a lot of rooms
and new issues
or agencies involved issues of progress
deserve to be considered very carefully
concerned around the three meters in
their build strip
to our bathroom tank to access the
software from the side
which is clipped by the patio
and one of the four parking spaces
concerns about the practicalities
of the council accessing the sun
by a three meter strip in an emergency
properties are defending markets
through and psychology crossing
government uncertainty over access
and damaged gardens access completely
distributed vents
which will create the unnecessary
obstacles
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
southeast
the next slide shows the application
side
[Music]
this is the side layout units
[Music]
[Music]
dispensing
our next slide shows the elevations
the next slide is a photograph from main
roads towards application sites
beautiful departments
our next slide is
[Music]
[Music]
with the rise of americans
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
meals
uh
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
um
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
thank you are there any questions
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i wish
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
if
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
this is
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
regulations
i
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
and
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
to grant commissions
in that condition that is
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
the reasons recommendations
should comprise our own planning issues
as necessary evolution
fails
that doesn't mean other recommendations
are automatically approved
rather you will need to take a positive
decision for further money
invading the recommendations
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
which
uh
[Music]
so for me looking at the previous motion
uh
to reject one's recommendations on a
previous application
they stand on this same application
and especially what
[Music]
uh
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
is
opportunities as well as to remove
[Music]
um
um
[Music]
and respect of affordable housing on
previously developed sites
here is that there should be substantial
harm here
so i remember the discussion council
foster and i had about the
level of substantial harm
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
based on the first part of the last
using used for the last application
but it's not acceptable i mean
[Music]
is
[Music]
you will take
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
at the same time
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
previously
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
are you comfortable
[Music]
and my understanding
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
yes
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
recommendations
[Music]
um
[Music]
yes
[Music]
in this
[Music]
300 case between it from the adjoining
property
property chair sixth grade an
established residential area
in drum fields money policies cherry one
new development
to respect the area in which they are
located compasses
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
such as requiring certain
[Music]
the first slide on page 48 identifies
the
application site in brown
boat colour and that's the
property next to the crime goes up to
its eastern edge
[Music]
[Music]
on page 49 the education site outlined
in red and then on age 15
the application element itself in that
red
area edge in green
and then patience one chair shows the
property
as it currently exists with page 52
showing the extension
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the application site it's the white
property that's
part hidden by the tree that's from
garland
you can see the drive that i've just
made reference to
the right of the asian side gen and the
other
[Music]
the
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
thank you yes thank you uh
the reason i honestly returned to your
committee was because
the concerns
thank you
[Music]
dating from the 1930s are
everyone
he doesn't believe that that's extending
this particular property to the side
elevation
um would not cause any significant
income in fact
i believe it will totally imbalance
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
um
thank you thank you are there any
questions
thank you um
and obviously here the uncooking is an
issue
i'm struggling looking at this to see
how i won't raise any more apart
um
any other questions
i can answer
these speakers
okay
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
thank you thank you
[Music]
take a number of concerns um firstly
integral considerations which are
crucial for discrimination and education
aren't fully considered report in
our view therefore the reports is still
in that sense
in the first instance you shouldn't
cover all the injections raised by
applied digital
protection
fully understanding the impact
development of how the immunity is not
client
and they can't be expected to be able to
make decisions in full possession of
impacts
secondly the support because officers
develop carry out proper analysis
distinctive quality of the timescale
and of all these detached villages
including enough identification sign
made
at distributed quality as such an
argument inaudible
regardless of circumstances a following
telling of the times of priority is
absolutely crucial
for the determination of its application
and if the assessment has been properly
carried out
we consider the officer which comes to
an entirely different recommendation any
social analysis will identify the
primary element which makes the fields
an attractive feature
is that regimented gap between 1.75
meters
which separates each one allowing them
to sit apart one another
and this is showing the conversation and
55.
it's a distinctive characterizing reach
for the township and his disapplications
are proved that after almost disappeared
it will have been eroded by 80 creating
a cherishing effect
attention and uncomfortably future
thirdly is
involved
[Music]
it focuses on unpaired output or per
assessment of the
enterprise policies it can't present
that forward proper balancing exercises
in making their recommendation this
fairly prevents any decision
and
[Music]
bio analysis applications important
policy in two main areas
firstly as i just described the times of
impacts proposals will create languages
in congress
[Music]
there's no development of the products
contributing to a total online
seventy-four percent
overall the properties original
construction four area
secondary house conference presidential
community
[Music]
the
[Music]
this application can be sent to protect
[Music]
[Music]
thank you are there any questions
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
the
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
um
[Music]
if
[Music]
says
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
of the house next floor to me
syndrome um and um
[Music]
on um and gs5 which is
[Music]
[Music]
just to um
ask whether cancer hospitals go on to
make reference to
what was the age fine and also
any relevant policies which aren't
whether
[Music]
[Music]
uh
is
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
um
[Music]
in consultation
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
again
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
associated
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
site is located
[Music]
[Music]
overall is not overriding the deciding
new problems likewise
[Music]
[Music]
is
just run through the presentation share
the defenders now start on page 57
[Music]
[Music]
site area in red yesterday the
scientific chair preference
was made before area of buildings
[Music]
392 square meters
from the other side with his chair the
site ozil is on age 59
showing the four terrorist queues there
are
who lies in front elevation and the box
store and windows
career shows garden areas
to read the properties and the parking
area
between the application sites and
forward roads
additional interest in placement that's
not considered to be
detriment to any other party and then
finally here we have some photographs
even on day 61 let's say photography
existing
which is buildings you see the comprised
of
stonework and state roof as its proposed
network details building is currently
on news as you can see there which has
that enabled my standing to its frontage
[Music]
the site which made reference to the
officer report
age 63 has a wider shot showing the
development was proceeding when the
photograph
was taken into the rear of the site that
is now completed
we'll
and then finally
um
[Music]
you
is um
[Music]
um
[Music]
is
impacts and immunity lost a lot much
lower
in the conservation area uh lack of
super parking in an already struggling
area and significant safety highways
issues
on the busy lane road dcc
[Music]
[Music]
our own highways authority county
council recommended its official
response
that a minimum of three car
[Music]
authority on such a significant matter
the council has recently scrutinized
our condition and master districts and
notice those are significant pressures
and parking in our area from home
is
this affirmation has significant impacts
on the immunity of blood presence
including loss of privacy
to nearby households and this planning
plot is
[Music]
[Music]
consultant
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
is
which was
[Music]
um
um
parking and um uh
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
today is
[Music]
were five applications for changes to
the witch's arm ranging from
rear extensions hulling and pruning of
trees
and these were all passed by any easy
final department with condition for
attacks
in 2017 november an application
have used the public house to issues of
the driving many shop
the applicant asked for a newspaper
article
delivered without two times in 2016
concerning the lack of facilities in
mastering
which raised the question is this
[Music]
[Music]
successfully as a growing concern and
the community was very pleased with the
prospect of having
a small shop with within walking
distance of most of their
homes and then in march 2018 when
commissioners
there were 10 conditions related to the
parking spaces of olivia population
along with facilities for the retail
business
the main reason the foundation 3 was in
the interest
of highway safety 2018
applications into the car park
of the vacant country's arms to present
presidential news
or three detached drawings with car
parking
gardens in the muslim conservation area
still nowhere have been taken to request
accommodating the budget
accommodation and shop 2019
june there was only time relating to the
first preserved
existing perigee on the site the
application was granted
with a list of foundations spaciously
provided a storage of plants and
materials
the size should be retained free from
any equipment
the design designated used throughout
the construction period
any full bus or highways should be
reinstated
august 2019 the application
is charged conditions granted the
stumble work had taken place because
2020 application was made to demolish
the former fully housed
and replaced with four houses and one
for their house there was 14 of the case
[Music]
all right
[Music]
is
[Laughter]
[Music]
the center of the village it's opposite
from a warm water
and as such it's been the subject of
many christmas cards
postcards and no doubt photographs as
well
the original astrologer
[Music]
will get shot
but now we're looking at an application
four large houses nice and affordable
in as well i think he's better suited to
the outskirts
of the built-up area and not the center
the focal point of a village
so it can completely change the look and
feel of that
village and also
[Music]
air force i'm also very
um concerned about closure football
british marsh lake is thousands apart
from australia
and we're very proud of our network
footpaths
and so it's really really disappointing
to think that we're going to lose this
one finally i would like to say that i
do understand
that planning is subject you know to
strip the eyeliners
but i do feel that i think a lot of
people
[Music]
at the end of that
thank you
thank you
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
tomorrow
[Music]
[Music]
from
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
thank you very much
[Music]
um
[Music]
thank you very much
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
is
[Music]
thank you any other questions
thank you very much
[Music]
are there any questions
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
um
we
[Music]
there is one ensuite bedroom
and a further bedroom that's shown
and then the artistic counterparts
and there is a further bedroom show at
second floor
so it's depicted with three bedrooms
explaining that as well as record on the
first floor there are two bedrooms in
the office
with the second story level for the
bedroom so plans three bedrooms
and one office from a point of view of
planning i think it would be possible
but i think
highly absolutely to say that the office
should only use as an office
guarantees members it couldn't be used i
say that for
a simple reason i think to condition it
to be used for a particular use
would deny an impossible to enforce
because it would be
gaining access to the property
inspecting the level of
furniture that's in that room
[Music]
for dwelling houses
four bedrooms and over it would normally
only be exactly
two spaces per unit and as you'll
heard there are sufficient car parking
spaces
[Music]
itself the overriding issue is whether
we were without a level of argument
would be detriment to
highway safety so very mindly advising
i moved off to spaces and we would
meet that
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
i
[Music]
[Music]
with almost three spaces yeah
four properties two spaces
twelve spaces and there's two spaces uh
that means
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
so the recommendation behind this
project
[Music]
is very easy
and i apologize
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
to you content class in this case the
highway authority needs
its assessment however it does have
different standards
yes it does recommend requests
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you any questions
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
difficult to measure little because it's
got various
elements to it so it is an approximation
into the
dentist although what i would say is
that
in super poor area it's um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
there is
thank you
[Music]
but some
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well this is
[Music]
um
uh
[Music]
the archaeology
1876 uh
is a historic site a decade
who would argue that the building is
[Music]
rather
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
mr
[Music]
they're not sustainable
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
the conservation area and you have
special regards to
preserve your enhancement conservation
area so i think the
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
says
[Music]
[Music]
and
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
thank you um
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
my own mind
[Music]
um
[Music]
is
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
regarding the market
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
um
[Music]
impact on is
and
[Music]
which
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
um
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
oh
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
was actually
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
my concern is that initially
um a shop was going to be built on that
area
and i think as a planning committee or
i don't know how he can do it but
something like that
we should have contracts signed up so
that they say that
that area needs a sharp it's part of the
planning
you know planning regulation that they
have and anything else that they'd be
able to
find
[Music]
express myself that well what i'm trying
to say
if we had said right you want to build a
shop there
that area is ideal for a shop because
there isn't one there for those people
then this
up by them is say right that stays in
place
and anything that you build anything
over and above that
then it comes to the planning committee
because then that hasn't been accepted
i know by the people of marsh lane
because that's what they wanted
and i just don't know whether that's
something that we could consider
as a planning you know in the future for
other areas that don't have those
facilities and you know planning
application comes in and that
condition
[Music]
[Music]
i think maybe we should be looking at
[Music]
things
[Music]
okay ladies and gentlemen thank you very
[Music]
much